well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages as they come in
in the next half hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
observer's chief leader writer
sonia soder and soon too the daily
mail's political editor jason groves
just
reestablishing our link with him but
hello to you in the meantime sonia great
to see you
as ever so pre-budget let's check out
the front pages shall we the metro then
reporting that the
chancellor will keep the furlough scheme
running until october
to try to avoid job losses once lockdown
is lifted that's also the lead for the
guardian with the headline
sunac extends the safety net
daily express says the chancellor is set
to put another seven
billion pounds into the scheme
the eye points out that by the autumn
the fellow initiative
will have been running for 18 months the
telegraph suggests rishi sunak will
focus heavily on bounce-back funding
as data shows the effects of the
pandemic slowly receding
england football legends jeff hurst
speaks to the sun
to back boris johnson's offer to host
all games in the
european championships this summer if
they can go ahead
and the delhi star has a story about a
couple who just
missed out on winning 182 million pounds
on the lottery that's bad isn't it uh it
says sonny cedro here jason groves very
soon as well
um well there's no no escaping the main
story and i have to say
sonia it's normally really exciting on
pre-budget night because we get a big
revelation about what's coming
what's left in that red box to tell us
about we know nearly everything don't we
that's a good question anna but uh rishi
sunak
is quite a canny political performer so
i assume that there'll be
one or two things that he's held back
but the big story on
all of the front pages tomorrow is
something that we were sort of expecting
uh the chancellor to announce which is
that the furlough scheme will be
extended for another three months
and it will take us to the start of
october
and i think that news will be a huge
relief to people who have been
furloughed these past four weeks
during our third national lockdown it's
gonna be expensive obviously as you'd
expect it's quite a generous support
scheme so it's it's probably gonna cost
in the region of
seven to ten billion pounds but i think
uh the sort of relief that you're
hearing from employers
really highlights the fact that this is
something that um
both employers and employees really felt
was needed and indeed the sort of main
attack line from
labor tonight is why didn't the
chancellor
announce this a few weeks back just to
give people that reassurance that they
need
needed that the support was going to be
there there are a few other tidbits
in the papers as well um some of them
we've sort of seen briefed in the last
kind of two or three weeks
but one thing that i think is a bit
disappointing is that the government is
deciding to extend
the extra 20 pounds a week into
universal credit
at the start of the pandemic but only
for six months
and i think this is a bit of a stingy
move considering when you look at what's
happened over the last decade of
austerity
you've seen some families with parents
in low-paid
jobs lose thousands of pounds a year in
tax credits
so that 20 pounds extra a week was
really really needed at the start of the
pandemic it didn't make up for those big
losses of the last decade
lots of families were still worse off
and i think the idea that it's only
going to be around for another six
months when
you've got an independent organization
like the resolution foundation
saying that unemployment we've not seen
the worst of it yet and it's to come
i do think that that's really worrying
okay well let's bring in the daily mails
political editor jason groves who joins
us for the first time
uh welcome to you great to see you on on
budget eve
uh we were just saying that normally
it's a really big deal but there's been
so much revealed already
uh what is left we know there's going to
be money for sport don't we
theaters museums and so on we found out
about that last night
tonight we're finding out about furlough
uh the extension of that more grants to
for the for the self-employed um but
going back to furlough which is the big
headline in most of the papers like the
metro for example as well
and will that be universally welcomed do
you think do you think some people think
it's time to you know for employers to
to bring people back to work effectively
no i think it will be broadly welcomed i
think there's a consensus around
the furlough scheme what i think it will
do though is sets of alarm bells
the chance is going to go quite a bit
further uh than we were expecting he's
uh
we've been expecting it to run to the
end of june when the roadmap runs out
now it's going to september and the
telegraph pick up on this
uh in their front page tonight uh
suggesting that
uh it demonstrates that the government
thinks actually people
uh and business are not gonna be fully
back
to work until uh potentially the end of
september
uh which slightly begs the question
about
what's going on in the meantime you know
we've got this message coming from
number 10 that
uh by june the 21st it's going to be a
big bang and we're going to be back to
normal
the chance on iran since we're
suggesting well we could be well into
autumn and who knows what might happen
after that
it's worth reflecting as well i think
that when the chance to launch this
scheme
uh uh back at the start of the first
lockdown last month
it was due it was due to uh youtube
until at the end of may last year
and as the eye uh points out tonight
we're now looking at 18 months
of furlough a scheme that was originally
due to last only
only for two or three the i then budget
2021
18 months of furlough and who would have
predicted that extraordinary
and in fact it's worth remembering i
suppose that when we looked at modeling
um on the night that uh boris johnson
unveiled the roadmap back on the 22nd of
february sonia
a lot of the modelling did show cases
rising again
in the summer which is why you had
jonathan van tam so specifically saying
that the most important bit for him
was to wait these five weeks between the
elements of lockdown
to see what this difficult variant the
b117 actually does to cases
i think that's right i think what you're
seeing is the government being much more
cautious this time boris johnson being
more cautious
far more than he was last summer far
more even than sort of
october november when he was thinking
about christmas plans and i think that
reflects the fact that he's been burned
by acting very uncautiously and that has
been one of the things that's
contributed
to such a terrible second wave and the
awful death rates and numbers of people
dying a day that we were seeing at the
beginning of january
so i think it's very welcome that uh
boris johnson
is treading more cautiously this time as
jason sort of hinted
there is a group of mps in the
conservative party you know they dub
themselves a coveted recovery group
who aren't particularly happy about this
so and they
would like the government to be moving
faster
but i have to say that i think that i
personally think the government's
um doing the right thing you know boris
johnson he has been burned before when
he talks about
sort of making himself a hostage to
fortune and saying this is going to be
the last lockdown we're never going to
need to do this again
but i think there is very very much a
desire in number 10 to make sure that we
we don't have to move to the same sort
of social restrictions that we saw in
january again now obviously vaccines are
going to
massively help with that but there are
things you know on the scene like new
variants
um you know that until we're all
vaccinated there may still be risks to
the nhs so i think that's why the
government
is taking this cautious approach and as
you hinted anna
one of the problems last summer was we
just kind of relaxed everything at the
same time so it was very hard to know
what was really responsible for that
uptick in infections that we were seeing
at the end of the summer
that really kind of laid the base for
this um terrible kind of second wave
that we saw in december january and
january
so i think there is a desire to go more
cautiously this time
step by step obviously doing schools
first
because it's it's school kids who are
really suffering the most out of school
i think
yes not long to wait we're all counting
down the days i certainly are
obviously everyone laughs but it's true
isn't it um but let's go to the guardian
now because it's quite interesting there
you really show thank goodness that
government borrowing is cheap right now
jason because there it is
piling money on top of money um they say
one year
15 spending interventions 280 billion
pounds spent it uh
it shows it quite clearly doesn't it
jason
it's absolutely extraordinary and uh you
know where
if you cast your mind back a year
uh rishi sunak was parachuted into
uh the treasury very short noticed his
first budget
uh and at the time he uh he brought
forward
12 and a half billion pounds uh of
support for the economy
and uh everyone at the time thought that
that might be enough
uh now he was back after only a few
weeks with it looking like a sort of
peashooter in this war against uh
covert it was nowhere near enough and as
the guardian pointed out he's in fact
been about 14 times
since uh and who's to say that tomorrow
will be the last one i mean i think
you know we're expecting him to uh at
the cost of this new support on furlough
and on some of the other things that
they're going to keep going like
business rates and the
vat cut and so on they're going to cost
somewhere between
30 and 50 billion so you can that
guardian graph can go up a little bit
further
and i wouldn't like to bet on this being
the last time
uh that the chancellor has to come uh to
parliament and announce more funding
for cobit i wouldn't be at all surprised
if we see uh
some additional help when the opening up
starts and uh
things go wrong and let's hope they
don't then he could it could be back
sooner rather than later so it's a very
useful sort of graphic illustration now
just how far we've come and
of course there's now a huge debate uh
within the conservative party for
starters but also within labor
about how on earth will you pay this
money back and we've seen some of that
erupt today i mean
the chances ally uh william hague saying
uh yes it is time to start uh putting up
taxes both on people and on businesses
uh slapped down earlier really by the
business secretary saying um i don't
agree with that at all
the way out of this is to go for growth
and i think it's fair to say
that there's already some tension in the
cabinet about it that hasn't burst out
into the open yet
but tory mps openly saying
that that they've grown back tax rises
and labor is split as well kirsten was
not quite sure where to position himself
he wants to look more for business and
more responsible on the economy
but the labour left is saying well hang
on a minute we're not gonna sit there
uh and oppose uh advising corporation
tax from some of the fat cat companies
we've been complaining about for years
yeah that's interesting isn't it it felt
like a
turnaround for a while um jason you do
sound a little bit like a dalek
so we might say goodbye to you for now
and see you after the break with
your own story of front page of the
daily mail which is very interesting as
well so we will see you shortly
and try and improve that it's quite
interesting wasn't it um
in the meantime that issue of tax
when to increase taxes how to do it is
kind of fundamental to
the years ahead isn't it now sonia
that's absolutely right and i think
there's two questions facing uh the
chancellor at the moment it's at what
point
is it right to start trying and getting
some of you know filling that black hole
in the budget at what point
is it right to start raising taxes and
you know there's one school of economic
thought which is actually when the
economy is doing badly that's
just not the time to write to increase
taxes you ride it out
you take on the debt particularly when
interest rates are very very low and
it's very cheap
for the government to borrow and then
you can put taxes up later
once the economy's doing better so that
thinking is by putting taxes up you sort
of
get in the way of economic growth
because you dampen consumer and business
confidence further and that's definitely
a school of thought i ascribe to you
but then there's this second question
which is when you're going to
increase taxes who's gonna bear the
brunt of it uh and which taxes are you
going to put up
i think what's so interesting is some of
the briefing that we've seen about the
tax rises that rishi sunak is
considering
it's sort of the exact opposite of what
george osborne and philip hammond have
done in the treasury over the last 10
years so
you know they slash immigration tax and
they also cut
income tax and rishi sunak is looking at
pulling them up
sorry to uh to rush you've got lots to
pack in in the second half but
we will see you then and jason hopefully
at dalek on no dalek
uh including his story in fact could nhs
staff be
forced to take the covert vaccine that's
what jason's sources say and he'll tell
us more about that in just a minute
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh let's go straight to
the daily mail and in the absence of
jason groves
to tell us about his exclusive because
we can't get him back because of
technical issues
now and you'll have to talk about it
this is nhs staff
could be forced to have the jab sonia
they um jason's suggesting this is a
radical plan
considered for thousands who turn it
down this has been mooted hasn't it and
it will be controversial
it is and it's something that's been
talked about in recent weeks
um you know unions in the nhs are sort
of quite opposed to the plan because
i think they would make the point that
it's better to convince people
proactively that they need to have the
job rather than making it a condition of
employment
but it is concerning so we know that i
think it's one in five the weekend
papers were reporting one in five
nhs staff haven't had the jab in some
care homes it's it's actually much
higher than that and that's uh
particularly i think
in some bame communities there's a lot
of vaccine hesitancy
there's a lot of misinformation doing
the rounds um for example
around whether the vaccines are safe
obviously they they are safe
um and they have been tested so it's a
really tricky one because
you really don't want members of staff
petting themselves
and other very vulnerable people who are
coming into hospital some of whom may
not be able to have the vaccine for
health reasons
you don't want them putting them at risk
but at the same time
you know it's not great for staff morale
to force people to have a vaccination
you really want them to be positively
taking it up so
i'm not quite sure it's the way forward
but the fact that it's being considered
shows how big concerns are
yes the mail can reveal the article says
that a review of vaccine passports
will consider whether health staff who
decline an injection
could be legally obliged to have one and
the v will also
look at whether compulsion should apply
to care home staff
most of whom are not implied by the
state employed by the state
so that will be interesting um quick i
apologize for the time
uh 30 seconds on nicolas sturgeon nine
o'clock tomorrow morning we hear her
evidence
yeah it's nicholas sturgeon's big day so
this is the story about alex salmond
her sort of mental uh allegations of
sexual misconduct um against him
two big questions for sturgeon when did
she find out about them and did she
mislead the scottish parliament and then
the scottish government investigation
into alex hammond
it looks like there may have been
problems with that i think in normal
times
if this goes badly for sturgeon it would
have been a resigning matter
but she's so important to the
independence campaign i just can't see
her the smp
sort of um uh pushing her out okay sonia
we will see you
and jason groves hopefully at 11 30.
thank you